[Music]
for most of my life I was told that I
was never gonna be able to throw a curve
ball let alone pitch because of my
condition looking back on it I just want
to prove people wrong I just go up there
I grab the ball and I think to myself I
run this game
[Music]
growing up my mom my dad they wanted me
and my brother to play sports find
something that we love I got a lot of
stares and a lot of questions but for me
I was just like yeah I was born with it
like I don't know any other way this is
me Dylan has Proteus syndrome once a
baby it's born their body parts never
stop growing and the first five years of
his life he had six surgeries but
Dylan's been able to deal with those and
adapt in my case it was my fingers and
my toes I can't really move these three
fingers and then these two I had issues
that most people take for granted like
buttoning up a shirt the sleeve ones
those are the worst he thinks that if
you can do it he should be able to do it
and he figures out how to do it
baseball has always been my favorite
sport but I've had some obstacles
because I've had to figure out how to
catch because I can't squeeze my glove
and it's the same thing with my
curveball
most people have both fingers on it but
I just used one and I learn a new grip
the way the ball comes off of his middle
finger and ring finger he just gets a
lot more spin than normal people do it
turns out because of my condition I can
throw a curveball that few other
pitchers can even though I wasn't the
fastest pitcher and I didn't have the
greatest body for pitching I always knew
that I could pitch because I was
accurate and I could hit my spots when
Dylan came here as a freshman he was
never a guy that we thought was gonna
contribute as much as he did and almost
by accident he got his opportunity
we were playing our rival school in the
second game of the year and our pitcher
was struggling Dillon was the only
pitcher on the bench and he threw three
scoreless innings and then we kind of
knew at that point that we had something
after that my er ei was the second best
on the team the highlight of the year
for me was when I came two outs shy of
filling and no-hitter a lot of people
were surprised but I knew that I could
do it and it just showed everyone that
I'm a good pitcher my family was always
loving and said just be you everything
will work out